we're back listen you guys happy to see
us leave a like and a comment we need to
see it from you guys let's go put a one
in the chat put a two in the chat that's
whatever you want to do just put in the
chat okay it's like we're back
it feels weird to film out we never we
were never gone no
so for all the viewers watching some of
you are confused uh just to be fair we
didn't warn you guys all right we
literally have it in the video tile
we're gonna be taking a month break two
seconds the conspiracy of some of you
bro yeah that conspiracies all they got
their thing shut down because you know
what happened was is when they when it's
youtube because when they went after
these mother what happened legal action
you're getting true no that's not what
so what happened was the lawyer told
them to chill yeah but i want to ask you
how did you take advantage of this time
if at all because i noticed like when
you came back you had a chinchilla
jacket like you changed
you had to say well you don't like this
yeah yeah yeah bro you don't like this
team's key
he's kid bro what's [ __ ] mean no i
mean i've been i've been enjoying that
jacket's fresh
thank you
i saw it i was like i want one yes and
you could afford one and i could afford
one now so i was like let me get that
yeah cause it is what is the bag of
chips that's a great reaction for you to
have people see me like [ __ ] can't you
afford anything else but you can i can't
you don't give a [ __ ] no i don't you do
not give a we're two different
[ __ ] for that absolutely we do
even when i was broke bro
i'll still manage to [ __ ] you know
what i mean yeah you know what's funny
people see me it's like yo apple stop
advertising manscape i'm like nah this
is just a free shirt that's a free shirt
i'll take it you know what i mean it's
kind of nice it feels good manscape sure
whatever i'll give it
i'll wear anybody it could be
it don't matter if it's free
watch school say
i was just thinking if the kkk came in a
fire shirt would i wear it okay would
you make a shirt a person fit with never
mind um
[Laughter]
and you know what [ __ ] the way they
hated the black lady they
[Laughter]
[Music]
um interestingly enough this topic kind
of crosses over with the freedom convoy
now you know in canada where we're at
specifically in montreal the lockdowns
have been pretty intense a lot of
curfews can't go out everything's shut
down a lot of business is completely
done for
so last two years have been interesting
and at the onset of the pandemic uh our
mantra since we couldn't do stand up we
couldn't go out do a lot of things that
we enjoy was we're going to just invest
ourselves into youtube and pump out a
lot of content try to keep that creative
juice going pretty much yeah and that's
what i did i would lock myself in like
seven eight nine days a week
i don't even know there was that many
days what is a week who knows when you
don't leave the home what is the sun if
you don't open your curtains okay um
have you gone out to do the market like
to go to do the groceries during that
period yeah no exactly no no
i was not out
i would not go out sometimes i wouldn't
eat i would look left everything was
just dead i was just working okay i know
i know i was there here's the thing i'm
the type of person where i could i could
survive in pretty much any environment
right it's why like military i can shut
off my brain and just get yelled at this
kind of environment i can just stay home
for months and i can do that
but just because i can't doesn't mean
it's good
if you're not
just because you can doesn't mean you
should like with the wonderful uh
philosopher i believe it was uh chris
rock said
you could drive your car with your feet
it doesn't make it a good [ __ ] idea
exactly hey your credit ain't that great
ain't it i've been in that position i
understand that i might have a little
something for you the extra card you see
extra is a debit card that helps you
build your credit back up
how does that work really simple you
take the extra and your subscription you
link it to your bank account
and then extras gonna spot all the
purchases the daily purchases that you
do on that account you automatically pay
the next day and at the end of the month
italians up all the purchases that you
did it sends it to your credit bureau
voila no credit check no fee and on top
of that you can get redeemable points
and rewards that you can use later ain't
that great all that with the extra card
listen go in the link below and you can
help build your credit back up today he
might put the link here
or maybe there let's on the side
whatever go check out the link get your
extra card today
and so for the last year and a half i
did that and you know from a work
perspective it's fantastic it put a lot
of visibility on us we hit the wave at
the right time like everything kind of
fell into place from a work perspective
and i'm but
grateful for all that but i can't
discount the fact that there's been a
lot of positives from the fact that you
just put your nose down and you do it
non-stop and
and something works
however
i'm not somebody who derives all my joy
or my well-being from being super
invested in my work
i like a balanced life definitely right
i can stay indoors and do that for
months but if i know myself i love
social activities i like going out
dancing i like going out to clubs i like
going out to comedy shows i like
performing i like going on the road i
like doing all that stuff and you know
the worst thing in what i don't consider
you an outside dude
you know what though
you don't consider me that in regards to
you
and regardless because you're more more
social than most people i'm outside but
if you were keeping it a stack i'm more
social than most people definitely
because you catching me at the club
definitely every week or every year
absolutely five times a week i give it
to you right granted so i need that
energy for me it's really important why
because doing things in a social setting
for me brings me a certain sense of joy
a little bit of community togetherness
seeing people you like there's something
nice about that yeah it is it is
and interacting with people there's so
much you can interact with [ __ ] zoom
yes what are they trying to do what do
they call me to do shows on zoom i'm
like [ __ ] no that's a no one girl i
know one comedian i know her name is
joseon shout out to usually
bro she told me that one day she had a
gig it was at 10 in the morning
comedy in front of lawyers
everybody had their camera and their
their their their microphone shut down
yeah so she's just talking to a void
yeah they get paid they get paid they
get paid but that's not how you want to
do comedy no no that's not how you want
to do your thing no so
i had to i had to spend the last two
years adjusting to not seeing people
okay and like i said i could survive i
won't complain about it is what it is
but it took its toll on me and i think i
was realizing that because even like
health-wise i was starting to feel it
you know i mean being sedentary for so
long not having the social activities
that really encouraged me to be out
there physically moving not having that
affected me and it took its toll i
started having health problems i never
had before even mentally i was like oh
man this is not this is not fun but i
still just
shrugged it off because i'm like that's
what we do but i got to a point where
i'm like you know what i could stand to
take a break we've had a fantastic year
it's been great with work let me just go
out and do something because i'm not the
type of person who just wants to beat
his head against the wall and see how it
ends up i'm gonna say like all right
well this wall's not gonna break let me
just go somewhere else and see if
there's a door okay this wall don't give
a [ __ ] about you they don't give a [ __ ]
okay so although we'll give a [ __ ] right
the government didn't seem like they
were going to open back up even when i
like even tried to take advantage of
stuff here i would like go out to a show
and a week later it's like shut down i'm
like bro i can't handle it's like having
an on and off relationship i'm not that
nick yeah we honor we don't know exactly
and if we're not just tell me we're on a
break
5 a.m close maybe i miss you [ __ ] no
that's what this vlog has been like my
prime minister he keeps hitting me
baby i miss you come back out to the
shows fifty percent capacity this is a
sign
we coming down again [ __ ] it's just us
receiving drunk tanks all day long i'll
be getting drunk tests all the time it's
us being it's us receiving drum text and
when we show up i miss you and when we
show up
[ __ ] fell asleep nah she got herpes
she got herpes she didn't tell you
all right so i'm dealing with this so
i'm like listen let me just take some
time so i ended up traveling right i
ended up going to london for some time
and
the reason why i went there is because
they had no restrictions no masks
everything is wide open max capacity so
i took advantage i signed up for every
activity under the sun [ __ ] i would
never do i want bingo pub crawls pub
quiz i don't give a [ __ ] i i went disco
so i understand
you i just want to do something i need
to go outside i need to do [ __ ]
i i didn't look at youtube people send
me licks are you too drunk i didn't give
a [ __ ] okay and i didn't realize how
much i needed that until i had that
about a minute i stepped out in miami a
minute yeah
yeah
breath of fresh air yeah
oh my god i felt good didn't it
yeah
you know what else is also weird oh my
god god no i was just about to say oh my
god another time because it felt so
oh
oh my god yeah just just being able to
just oh stretch it out yeah outside of
your oh it was amazing it was it's just
not even us just stretching out
here's another thing that um
i think is cool too is like when
everyone wears their masks indoor
outdoors it does something to you where
everyone is just kind of faceless
right
it's like you don't really see people no
you just see masks no it is a very
interesting thing where when your place
was like no match you all of a sudden
remember what it's like to be around
people it feels different and i was
reading up on a study of that for kids
it really affects their ability to
socialize and to feel connected to their
peers if everyone has mass kindness oh
you mean they have mask on at school uh
at the period where they can recognize
what
feelings are
is that you can't use the face
is that what you're saying is that are
you saying are you saying yeah that
being inside with the mask on where is
their time for them to know what social
interaction is
without a face is affecting them yeah
[ __ ] goddamn yeah
so i can wonder i'm not saying this to
drive social policy or anything like
that i'm just telling you guys about the
other side effects that i don't think
are discussed enough right and i think
for me i was definitely reaching a bit
of a point where i'm like bro this is
getting redundant i i can't live like
this and do this all the time so i'm
going to make an effort should this
continue for another year or however
long they're thinking and do this to
constantly take some time for myself so
i can find a good life balance because i
cannot afford to go back to that way of
life where i'm shut indoors all the time
and there's nothing people are like why
don't you go take a walk i'm not that
naked okay maybe you're a hiking person
if you are maybe this pandemic didn't
affect you too bad and i'm
congratulations i like social entities i
like going to the club i know that's
maybe a weird thing for some people to
say they don't get but i enjoy that i
like going to comedy shows that that
matters to me those were the things
that drove me to see people and to be
around folks right and so for me there
wasn't much of an ability to adapt
because you just removed everything i
loved right so
all this to say now we are at the point
where we're coming back and obviously
we're going to be producing videos and
we're excited but i wanted you guys to
understand a little bit of the mindset
of like why we decided to take such a
lengthy break and why it was good for us
it's really a matter of our environment
anyways all that to say no i've been
enjoying you know uh working on
different projects and working on the
other studio and making that thing work
trying to make it work clockwork get
the people um working for us for the
studio
to
you know get more knowledge about this
[ __ ] maybe now you know it's proper
proper so you know we're about to pop
off for this thing as well yeah because
if you didn't know we have another
channel called abba versus preach it's
not abba and preachers abba versus
preaches a lot of con like it's not the
same thing not the same for the
competitive field
this is like a podcast form those were
wondering this channel is not going
anywhere the other channel is not going
anywhere either it's just something else
there's gonna be a lot of new things for
you guys this year in terms of content
so whether you subscribe to patreon
whether you're here whatever it is we
are excited to give you guys what you
want you just released this
you just released this video how come
there's some
comments from five days ago patreon yeah
we're also going to be going on tour so
i'll just uh we'll be announcing that in
the near future so yeah look out for
that but city near you we're coming back
so we're back all right um we're trying
to enjoy
what we can hear as much as possible but
uh we'll try to take better care of
ourselves so that we can give you guys
as much as what you can but also just to
take care of ourselves so i guess i want
to just say that
no that's pretty much my thoughts
anything else you want to say in regards
not these circumstances nah chinchilla's
looking nice all right
if you guys enjoyed today's video leave
a like comment yeah put a blue pill i
don't give a [ __ ]